all right guys so we're gonna we change
up the set a little bit today because uh
we
we want to feel closer to you guys we're
right here
right here we can almost touch you it's
an experiment
and uh hopefully you guys respond well
to it and plus this makes me closer to
cat so
i like it hey guys i'm ryan wright
and i'm jerry and i'm kat welcome to
reasons to see where we give you reasons
to see and not to see 300 rise of an
empire so you and i
are going to hang out tonight
okay guys so uh today we're gonna spoil
it up for you guys because
i wanna make sure that uh we give you
guys something different so if you guys
haven't seen three underrise of an
empire we're gonna spoil some stuff
possibly
if you don't care about spoilers then
stick around enjoy the show
but yeah so 300 rise of an empire uh
this film is pretty sweet not like sweet
liz like it's cute or something i
thought it was a lot of fun
you know like the whole time it's just
people slashing each other up from like
beginning
to end i thought it was more violent
than the first one it was banana
sandwich crazy man non-stop gore
throughout i guess so i mean there's
there's there's a lot more talking in
this movie too though i don't know i
like any movie with a good fight scene
you can't really make a movie too
violent for me maybe when it's like
pointless
what i find really interesting is when
300 came out 300 was just like
oh my god look look at this what the
hell a lot of movies have pretty much
copied 300 yeah
and 300 really paved the way for a whole
movement in like television because we
get all these historical shows
even like the the bible show on the
history channel was like 300 out as well
it looked like zack snyder's the bible
and it's it's weird because this movie
kind of reminds me
of those shows that this movie that the
first movie
yeah they've almost created a genre it's
like a weird loop in a way
yeah and it looks cool like this film
still does look really cool there's just
a few scenes that i always walk away
thinking about like
eva green is awesome right yeah amazing
yeah she is incredible and there's just
a couple of moments where i'm like this
scene really defines eva green pretty
well
at one point she slices a guy's throat
then slices
the back of his neck tim pulls off his
head and starts making out with the
decapitated head
i remember just being like what am i
watching i don't get it it's business
yeah i didn't understand why she did it
but i was like this kind of makes sense
for her character the infamous sex scene
that everyone is talking about
more like a sex battle it's like yeah
it's like a fight scene but instead of
picking a specific martial art they
chose sexes
i would love to have sex like that one
day that just looks like a ton of fun
wouldn't you agree cat that that looks
like a lot of fun come on cat
agree with one sex thing on oh
whatever all right it's all right i'll
have sex with you that way ryan thank
you jerry oh
gosh i should just leave you guys alone
for a little bit come back but yeah no
this film was pretty this film was
pretty cool in that arena like the sex
scene was uh i could uh i could it was
really good i could break it down for
you yeah well choreographed
it was a well choreographed sex scene
like they punched each other
down and in the first 300 i felt like
there was a really kind of iconic sex
scene so they sort of made it a
tradition
i think yeah kept it going with this
movie well the sex scene in the first
300 was just
like yeah it's just images and this one
is like the camera just lets it play out
the first movie sex scene is like a 300
sex scene the second movie sex scene is
like a 300 fight scene
yeah yeah sometimes the tone was a
little bit like on and off like it would
go like okay now we're in 300 style now
we're in a more realistic world but
overall though
i still thought it was a lot of fun
regardless like the whole reason you're
gonna check this movie out is mainly
because of the visuals and action and it
totally delivers on
all of that yeah i mean it's it's it's
still act hacked it's still a lot of fun
it takes itself more seriously than the
first one yeah there aren't as many guys
on the battlefield who are clearly
enjoying the [ __ ] out of this that's
true
um so you do miss a little bit of that
but you know i i like the guy who was
the the leads uh the lead athenian uh
the mystically uh yeah and ava green is
awesome
yeah she's a really strong character the
athenians are not as ripped
as the spartans but it makes sense that
they're i mean
sometimes it's like why is this guy
who's just a regular worker some cut but
what i thought was cool about the film
was like these are just
men they're dealing with you know 300
those were like warriors at birth yeah
yeah
that's like the only thing they ever do
is be wary yeah and this one they had a
lot of most of them were just like
regular people who were fighters and
stuff and you know i don't know the
history historical story but
i i it does make me want to learn about
it you know greek history and stuff like
that is always interesting it seems like
oh yeah and another thing i thought was
cool about this was that they made all
the battles like navy bat naval battles
like battle at sea so that was like a
neat contrast
from the original movie especially
because there were a lot of different
ways in which you know the greek
military fought
well and i loved the timetable of the
storytelling it wasn't really a prequel
or a sequel it was kind of like
meanwhile this is what's happening over
here yeah yeah it's like prequel
spin-off sequel it's like yeah got all
those elements going on and uh
i love the finale of this film like i
thought it was great i totally had
chills by the time it ended yeah i
didn't want eva green to die i
i thought it would have been cool if
somehow they worked things out like you
knew she was gonna die but you were
still sad when she did yeah
she thought bravely i thought the role
of good guy and villain
was more uh established it was better it
was better than the first one because
xerxes comes in very late
into the in the first 300. in my
personal opinion he's kind of a joke
and he's just a drag queen in my opinion
and i guess that's the
idea in a way yeah well he's larger than
life you know like he believes he is a
god and and the whole point is to build
him up and then you finally see him and
you're like oh
interesting and he's a very i'm feet
tall yeah what was
the opposite of the you know smart
spartans and what they stand for i felt
like
you know they're not vain at all and
here's this like vainglorious made up
guy that's all
image and no fight and that's how you
would have retold that story as a
warrior anyhow like he was nine feet
tall
and covered in gold oh yeah okay the
first like
20 minutes of this it seems like it's
going to be a xerxes origin tale
because they're they're so focused on
like who xerxes was before he was just a
guy with hair and facial hair and his
daddy didn't really love him too much as
the film goes it's like oh xerxes takes
a dip in the pool and then he comes out
and he looks like the drag queen that he
is and then they kind of just go but eva
green's the villain now
from what i have been told that was
actually a rewrite decision because
originally it was supposed to be like
this is the xerxes story and i guess
based on a frank miller novel that isn't
out yet
it was supposed to be very focused on
xerxes and for whatever reason they
chose to not do that but eva green again
is like
i prefer watching her yeah i mean she's
so good in this it's not even funny no
it's kind of funny take that back jerry
in the uh the ending uh i like the
cliffhanger they had the cliffhanger i
thought was cool when
the spartans show up and then lena heady
is like [ __ ] just slashing up people
and you're like i didn't know this
chickie kicked so much
ass she's in the new battlefield i love
lena i knew she had it in her she's
she's awesome in game of thrones too
she's just one of my favorite actresses
she's great
yeah she's really badass i think she
definitely brought it for this one
just like she did in the first one she
probably has a great ass oh yeah i'm
sure she does
badass great ass you know bad great ass
when it ended i did have like a lot of
chills because i was like they're
finally
united the spartans and athenians
because that's been the whole problem
this entire time my only thing is i hate
cliffing your endings because i have to
wait so long for the next film to come
out i'm just like come on come
on what's going to happen would be
though there has to be another film they
can't just end it there
i didn't even read it as like a
cliffhanger so much as like well they're
finally united and they're gonna fight
some more and they're gonna win but i
have to
i have to see that happen well that's
the other thing is i don't know the
actual history of all this so i don't
know if it's a foregone conclusion that
they win
or if they're all going to unite fight
valiantly and this battle is not going
to turn out great and see the only way
to find out is to watch the next movie
i'm sure
you know i want to see xerxes get taken
down i want i want to see how he dies
yeah you're right xerxes is still around
i just thought they were just some great
fight scenes they're really well
choreographed i really liked the scene
where there was kind of this father-son
arc this father felt like his son wasn't
ready to fight the sun
was ready and then in the middle of the
battle he looks around and his son's
there fighting he just like kind of
looks like what the [ __ ] are you doing
here
told you to wait fighting together yeah
exactly i thought it was really well
done i thought
that was a great moment and it's a nice
reverse from the first movie yeah
exactly where they had the father-son
thing going on there too so
they do a lot of that which i thought i
think is really a great trick with
writing
and then when the dad died it was like
it was a little sad yeah it was like oh
i'm glad he didn't just get like some
quick death like yeah they let him have
his moment to give a little speech to
his son
that's true and i like the camera work
too i like the scene where it's like
following the arrow i thought that was
an awesome scene i really enjoyed that
you know what i like those are the
remnants of the original movie style
before they
you know because this movie sort of
combines the action style of the first
one and then mixes in its own visual
look
what i liked about the action too was
that the camera lets the action scenes
play out and
the first one it's very just super
stylistic with the camera the whole time
and this one it's just war a lot of time
war is just going into the battlefield
the whole time it was like watching just
fight scenes really play out and uh
man i just wish eva green didn't die
like i thought the dynamics between uh
demos colossiosis
and eva green was just really good and
yeah inspiring i wish she could make it
into the next one but somehow
and his performance is is that much
better when they are together
yes yeah they play they have great
chemistry yeah he finally has some charm
when he's around her you know
so what do you guys think are some
reasons to see it after talking about it
well there's a lot of eye candy
you know there's some really great
looking shirtless guys
eye candy the first movie but you
definitely get the ad this is for you if
you're not fantastic super ripped
look but you still want people who are
cut yeah yeah that's your movie
eva green would probably is another
reason for sure eva green
lena heady lena heady another reason
some of the center photography is just
awesome cinematography this is great
visual effects is still dynamite awesome
fight scenes
watching it in imax another great reason
to watch it very true
i guess the most scoliosis this would be
good too all right guys thanks for
checking out a review for 300 rides of
an empire why don't you go ahead
scroll that comment box below and tell
me what is your favorite sex scene
you've seen in the movie and once you're
done with that and before i have an
allergy attack
click this button this button there so
you can check out more episodes of
reasons to see
and last but not least if you want to
get updated every time one of our videos
or reviews or whatever awesome thing we
have is out
subscribe click on cat's head right here
right there click it were you giving the
middle finger no he's just pointing
oh you're pointing i thought you were
flicking off our subscribers
i wouldn't do that no no please don't
flick off our subscribers please cat
it's not nice i love our subscribers
i love our subscribers too cat put me in
the friend zone i can't believe this
[ __ ]
oh yeah i did i declared him she
declared it you know i've had a few
people say i just see you as a friend
but rarely does someone say to me you're
in the friend zone
it was straight up bluntness and my
heart just
it's true do you know what this is
we were on the phone that's uh the
smallest violin the world's smallest
island
yeah it's like a very sad song right now
just for you right
thank thank you the world's smallest
accordion
oh playing the gypsy version of this
song you know what this
is what cherry masturbating
well done
that's the joke that's the joke he's got
a small penis he's got a small penis
this is this is ryan masturbating then
what do i do
there's nothing don't make fun of my
vagina